[Music]
Silicon Valley is the center of
innovation but I never really had the
opportunity to experience that before
experiencing this on a daily basis
through mean and wide array of speakers
who have had more than 10 15 20 years of
experience in the field and sharing with
us some of their setbacks how they grew
what they learn from their mistakes and
actually what made them successful so
that was really key to me I was chatting
one out one of the mentors in my startup
project and he was able to connect us
with wide array of other potential
investors mentors who actually worked in
the same topic or similar topics or
faced similar problems so what was I
chartered for me was the fact that it
was kind of a snowball effect having
access to one person that has broad
connections gives you access to the
whole array of different expertise this
very unique aspect of snowball effect in
Silicon Valley comes from the fact that
all the innovation expertise and
investor are kind of concentrated within
a small space what surprised me a lot
about them is that they're so
accomplished and smart yet very humbled
and accessible and this is very critical
in my career as I think about my future
position as a future leader the Stanford
MSX program has been a turning point to
expand and strengthen my network in the
Silicon Valley to build long-lasting
bridges with the community here with my
classmates faculty and the broader
community in Silicon Valley being in
Silicon Valley is mind-blowing
[Music]